congratulations on going to the finals
the judges really seem to really dislike
the uh
saving rule which i think was invented
to
make sure that people with really really
low scores
and and a lot of votes might not
you know go through to the end or or
that
couples with higher score
more ability would go through um but
that doesn't seem to really
they just are stuck
choosing between two great dancers what
do you think about the saving rule
i think on a season like this where
there have been so many competitive and
really great dancers and celebrities
that it's been really tough on them so i
can understand why maybe this season
hasn't been their favorite because
you're choosing like you said between
two really great dancers
um
in my opinion for somebody like us when
we were in the bottom two i thought it i
really appreciated the saving rule
because you know we were in the bottom
and we ended up getting saved so
yeah
jojo like i said congratulations second
what would your grandpa have said of
that performance and your entire journey
here on dancing with the stars
well
i would probably go up to my go grandpa
what'd you think and he'd go not so loud
john jones
and then he'd say ah darling it was
incredible
also in my grandpa's country i don't
know wow
i think i think he'd be really proud i
do i think that he was very
straight to the point and he would tell
me it like it is and he was honest and i
think he would be
so proud
you know what i think he is so proud you
know in one way or another he's watching
and he's with us and
i think we did him good tonight
no jojo you had a plenty of celebrity
shout outs throughout the season but a
big one tonight was demi lovato
demi is
literally one of the best humans in the
world
uh we were texting all day today
they were so supportive of
literally this whole journey i mean i
remember when we first said that we were
gonna be two girls dancing together demi
was one of the first people that texted
me and then today
they were like
saying so many nice things about how
this is game changing how this is so
brave and just giving so much love and
support it's nice when
you look up to humans and then they're
actually genuinely good humans and
that's how demi is
given the unpredictability of this
season can you believe this has actually
happened that you're in the finale right
now
unbelievable i mean i remember week one
just wanting this moment
and now all i want to do is go back in
time because as great as this moment is
it means there's six days left
and i am devastated about that but these
six days i'm going to cherish every
single second every single moment
i'm
just so grateful
well after those six days your career is
now taking so many turns right now
but you're still going on tour where
your new fans are gonna see you and
now even your original fans are going to
come out in droves to see you if you
were to speak to them right now on what
to expect from a night out of a future
concert of yours what would you say to
them for something to look forward to i
would say
that it is my goal to make everybody
have a fun time at my concert there's
something for the little kids there's
something for the dads that bring the
little kids there's something for the
grandma and grandpas and there's
something for the teenagers it's a
concert for everybody and i cannot wait
to be back out on tour waited two years
for this can't wait for you to come and
see i'm excited
jenna doesn't know this yet but whatever
city she comes to i'm gonna have one of
these songs prepared and we're just
gonna you're gonna say a surprise pop-up
i love it
jojo what did uh and jenna what did it
mean for derek to say that this was the
best contemporary not just of the season
but of like the entire show
it was wild um
yeah i got very emotional i was trying
to pull it together but
derek is somebody that i respect
immensely
i feel like in a way he's been a mentor
to me i joined the show when i was 18
and he was on his way out of leaving
being a pro
and i just feel like i learned a lot
from him and i feel like he changed the
game of the show and how dance is
cherished and received and absolutely i
mean he's an emmy-nominated emmy-winning
choreographer you know so for him to say
that really meant a lot um and i
it's a moment i'll never forget that's
for sure
jojo what did you learn the most about
yourself during this whole journey oh
man that she loves crop tops
[Laughter]
okay
okay
i have learned that the one person in
the world that i don't love and that i
don't fully accept is myself
and
i it was put straight in front of my
face
by somebody i won't name names but by
somebody
that i
should
and that's one thing that i'm most
grateful for is that
jenna specifically has changed the way
that i think about myself look at myself
and
feel about myself